[Music]
foreign
this is talk TV
[Music]
good evening upstairs Morgan uncensored
tonight the rapacious rise of corporate
wokery a major Bank says sorry for
terminating Nigel farage's account over
his opinions do we really want to live
in a world where Banks Brands and
businesses are hooked on Force feeding
us their policies will debate that
four-star general David Petraeus LED U.S
forces in Afghanistan Iraq then took
charge of the CIA who better to talk
about the future of the Ukraine war how
will it end what does it all mean for
Putin he joins me live
that's National Treasure Delia Smith
becomes the latest celebrity to denounce
vegans as the market of a plant-based
gruel implodes I think veganism is As
Dead As the steak I'm having after
tonight's show notorious activist vegan
booty will be in the studio to try and
prove me wrong
[Music]
live from the news building in London
this is Piers Morgan uncensored
put my earpiece in that's one thing we
forgot so I couldn't hear the director
earlier uh it's actually a blessed
relief for both of us good evening and
welcome to Piers Morgan uncensored
capitalism is a colorful Riot of banks
Brands and businesses competing for our
cash we give them money they give us the
things we need or desire to make our
lives easier and less miserable that's
the deal but there's a problem they hate
you
well I don't seem to care if you know it
at some unidentified point in recent
history companies lost interest they
simply selling things and decided it was
their duty to change the way that you
and I think someone somewhere say
corporate board members of the World
Unite and suddenly the people who sell
you fizzy drinks and credit cards but
also telling you that black lives matter
that pride month is more important than
Christmas you're personally to blame the
climate change because of your filthy
carbon footprint and so on and so on
this week Coots Bank my own bank was
exposed for terminating Nigel farage's
account because of his divisive opinion
supposedly and his stance on brexit
here's Dame Alison Rose the CEO of
NatWest which owns Coots
the climate emergency is the biggest
challenge that we're going to face and
as as a bank and the leading Bank in the
UK we have a real role to play clearly
not enough money is going to female
entrepreneurs and there are too many
barriers in their way to helping them
succeed we have targets at our CEO minus
four level right the way through the
organization to encourage all elements
of diversity and inclusivity
well apart from including it seems Nigel
farage so her politics will be clear I
actually have to agree with some of her
causes and Views but also wonder what's
that going to do with my bank I disagree
with Nigel farage's opinions about many
things including brexit but I don't
think he should be denied access to
banking because of them is anybody well
Coots is tonight groveringly apologize
Nigel Farah I just said NatWest was
offered to find him alternative
arrangers but haven't offered him his
account back at Coots the treasury says
it'll toughen up his rules to make sure
this never happens again but the
reputational damage once again is done
it seems orwellian that it ever happened
in the first place and when it comes to
corporate wokery this is just the tip of
the iceberg Ben and Jerry's which sells
ice cream in America blame the United
States for the war in Ukraine earlier
this month it called for indigenous
lands to be returned to indigenous
people before it emerged in its own HQ
was built on land owned by you guessed
it indigenous people what's the lesson
there other than all this wokery tends
to be based on hypocrisy well maybe it's
just stick to selling ice cream
huh tried that old trick
Bud Light if you're wishing they'd stuck
to selling beer the drink of choice for
millions of sports loving working-class
Americans teamed up with trans
influencer Dylan Mulvaney who was a man
until last year and now spends most of
her time mocking women
um America's favorite Beer Company
decided that that she would be the
perfect person to sell their beer and
absolutely tanked their business because
most of their consumers went what are
you doing
well that debacle
has cost of 27 billion dollars so far
the same thing you might remember
happened to Gillette we suddenly told
all its male customers including myself
that we were a bunch of Harvey
weinsteins until we could prove
otherwise they took an 8 billion dollar
write down in value
it's corporate suicide
or maybe it's Maybelline the popular
lipstick Merchant last week decided to
tell women they should aspire to be big
bald men with beards when they buy their
lipstick really why why wouldn't you
think that would work why is no one in
your office is like me going what are
you doing you idiots
we'll see how it goes I can tell you how
it's going to go probably not very well
because most women don't buy lipstick
because a big bold bearded boat tells
them to
last month Adidas chose a biologically
male model complete with visible bulge
to advertise a female swimming costume
again why would you do that
this week we discovered that Disney has
abolished its seven dwarves in a
live-action remake of Snow White and the
Seven Dwarfs the doors have been
replaced by seven magical creatures of
bearing shape sizes ethnicities and
genders actually what that means is one
dwarf actor is still in that Phil about
seven dwarves and the rest are
average height people
so six door factors lost work in a
Hollywood Blockbuster because of wokery
Disney also abolished its famous princes
and princesses because they're gender
stereotypes really
can't we just have princes and
princesses anymore
but it does not feature gay kisses and
lots of diversity here's a Disney
executive explaining why
our leadership over there has been so
welcoming to like my like not at all
secret game like I was just wherever I
could just basically adding queerness to
like if you see anything queer in the
show I'm proud family but like I guess
it was like no one would stop me and no
one was trying to stop me
why didn't like someone stop you with
you adding acquaintance everywhere I got
no problem with being people being gay
or trans or anything frankly black white
I don't care I treat everyone the same I
expect them to treat me the same
but this stuff is utterly ridiculous why
does Disney which makes fairy tale
cartoons and adventure stories for kids
why doesn't he the queen this agenda
I don't get it and nor do the consumers
Disney's taken a huge hit as well
recently
I'm not even right-wing
you wouldn't believe it from the way I
get treated on Twitter people call me a
right-wing head banger not right wing at
all is to edit the Daily Mirror
newspaper it's a left-wing newspaper
I think I'm sort of around the center
somewhere really maybe slightly to the
left or over the years the left have got
so nuts I find myself sliding maybe
slightly to the right maybe
because the left has lost its mind this
woke stuff is insane and everyone's
getting seconds out of it not least sick
and tired of woke companies telling us
every day that we're evil until we can
prove otherwise I just want to buy an
ice cream I love ice cream without
dismantling the patriarchy whatever that
is
well joining me now at talktv Trio is
about oakshot Richard Tyson Paula Roan
Adrian Richard how is it come to this
that companies now feel a desperate urge
to impinge on the rest of us their own
supposed values and beliefs and if we
Veer from them we're somehow evil well I
think we're absolutely seeing that if
you go woke as a company you will go
broke and you've read out lots of
companies there who financially have
suffered and actually NatWest and Coots
will financially suffer from this no
question at all hopefully the lesson to
be learned out of this is we are
possibly at Peak wokeness but the reason
we've come to it is I think is because
of weak leadership on the boards of
directors of these companies who have
fallen for this stuff that has come from
from younger people underneath and they
haven't had the courage to say don't be
Daft where's the common sense stick to
doing a good you know producing a good
product and selling it yeah I've seen
this myself I saw it at ITV when I went
through my exit from Good Morning
Britain a lot of the aggro was driven
internally by Young wokies at ITV I know
you don't like the term but let me
explain what it means I do like the time
I like the term woke I support the term
woke because I know what it means what
do you think it means well it's not what
I think it means it's what I know it
means this is what and it's I know what
it used to mean well I wrote a whole
book about it number one bestseller
right same thing I know what used to
mean raising awareness to Social and
racial Injustice I get it right that is
not what today's woke means well today's
work is the news maybe that may be your
misunderstanding but I understand
today's work is what Coots have just
done to Nigel Farah no well by the way
no and I'm hang on let me ask you a
question okay I'm a Coots customer too
I'm not happy about this I rang them
yesterday they'd have a chat them about
it they wouldn't even talk to me about
it because they couldn't confirm that
Nigel farage is a customer right because
apparently creative protection is it
right except their their briefing left
right and Center to the media
here's my point is that the point I made
yesterday I'm going to make it again I
have a lot of what people think of
controversial opinions I don't think
they're very controversial but why are
my controversial opinions Allowed by
Coots and why are Nigel farage is not
and why if you believe in free speech if
you genuine liberal would anyone be
happy anyone be happy with someone like
farage regardless of his politics having
his bank account taken away because I
don't get it so so Nigel farage knows
better than anybody that we live and
work in a capitalist Society
as a private bank they have decided as a
bank they have decided that their
customer is undesirable did you rewind
it's under I I did come back
yeah you can respond to what she said
has decided that he's undesirable and
therefore no longer want to did you read
the reasons why I did read some reason
all of the reasons why I did because it
was actually shocking and and do you
know what a lot of it was down to his he
likes Novak Djokovic
most of the people on Twitter last week
irony of this is there's two the first
is as I understand it and you're correct
me Richard if we were still in the EU oh
here we go that wouldn't have been
allowed to happen no absolutely nonsense
the second thing is why are we concerned
about one millionaire when there are
over a million
income status who cannot get access to
bank accounts
all right Isabel you report all right
suffer because visit that I mean you say
that's all right but we're talking about
here's the truth here's the truth
this was happened to you just said the
complete opposite okay perfectly well
that it isn't just one millionaire you
know that this is the absolute tip of it
and that loads of organizations and
individuals are being debanked for their
political views well I'd like Nigel
farage the treasury is suddenly decided
you are of low income when your status
is not the same or considered to be the
same as Nigel farage
there's a Facebook page of ten thousand
NatWest customers can I ask peers how
strongly do you feel about this issue
pretty strongly actually because I think
it doesn't matter whether you're on the
left or the right the idea that a bank
is taking a form a view about people
based on their opinions because there's
no criminality attached to pharaohs that
has been on Earth they couldn't point to
any a lot of it was it gets on with
Donald Trump he likes Novak
completely ridiculous so my question to
you is and this maybe you think it's a
bit of a cheeky question it's only just
occurred to me why don't you shut your
account with well I want to talk to them
actually I do want to talk to you it is
only by people like you doing that the
organizations will realize
I've been recruits a very long time
they've always been very good to me but
I've got to say I find this episode
deeply deeply concerning and for the
boss of NatWest to say you know we
should never have done this yeah but a
lot of your Executives were involved in
this but yeah I've had accounts closed
by Metro Bank by tide it wouldn't give
me anything and just but with with cash
in for no reason they wouldn't tell me
why yeah with the Metro Bank it was with
the Reform Party account I gave a press
conference at the time they wouldn't
give any reason whatsoever I've
submitted subject access requests it'll
be very interesting to see what's so
tell me something with Nigel it's
awesome
it's actually a story about Nigel farage
and that is quite frustrating rating
that it has turned into a story about
one man whose feelings have been hurt
millions
they briefed Simon Jack at the BBC
deliberately and it turned out he was
sitting next to this woman the boss of
NatWest the night before at a dinner by
coincidence we don't know right but they
briefed him and he put out that it was
actually the real reason was Financial
he didn't have enough money in his
account it turns out that he's not true
when you read the full account in the
telegraph about this it turns out a
major part of their thinking actually
whether about his political views which
on the quotes of brexit that's half the
country right so this idea that because
he likes Trump and likes Djokovic and
you know and and may have may or may not
have known some Russian people whatever
none of this is a good enough reason to
kick off his account a huge percentage
of coots's own customers will agree with
Nigel on many many of these issues so
are they going to fire all of them I
mean but I would feel the same way if it
was someone on the left right so I don't
I don't take a partisan position too
many people I see responding to the
Pharaoh story take a partisan position
where if I was believing swapping names
right when you do a Biden story imagine
if it was Donald Trump right and so on
and the other way around and see how
you'd feel and if you feel the same way
that's your belief right whereas it's
not a partisan position and I can
totally agree with you on that which is
why I say this is not a Nigel farage
story it isn't but it has been played
out as if it's about you know the most
stupid thing about it you say that but
actually at the end of their assessment
as to why they were going to remove his
account they say we are aware this will
be a PR problem
issue a groveling apology to is playing
right into his hand of course because
he's a broadcaster and a politician of
course it empowers and helps him but
that's frankly the price you pay when
you do this kind of thing in a country
like agree with you where I agree with
you is it really sticks in the throat to
hear Coots talking about inclusivity
and are the most exclusive banking
houses there are I mean that and that
again I just found that laugh anyway I
will be talking to Coots and there'll be
an interesting conversation because I
think they only think I want to talk
about pharaohs actually I want to talk
about myself thank you am I going to
have to cancel am I going to read one of
these reports about My Views and if not
actually why not right I mean either be
consistent or don't but I get it on the
program I I will ask the boss of Coots
to come on I'd love that uh and I think
they should have a proper conversation
about what makes a reasonable person
because actually you should submit a
subject access request from Coots about
you be interesting reading it would be
interesting
maybe not not be too hasty here
um you prompted this let's turn to web
weaponized incompetence women are
starting to call out their men the lack
of responsibility over child uh over
household Jewels with videos mentioning
the term weaponized incompetence
receiving a one and a half or 148
million views on ticket let's take a
look
I'm going to show you guys what
weaponized and competence is it's
something my baby daddy loves to use
against me very very well last night I
went to bed at like 10 I asked him hey
can you please clean the bottles right
if I were to ask him hey I thought I
asked you to pick up the kitchen last
night oh well you only told me to clean
the bottles and I did clean the bottles
you didn't tell me to put the food away
and you didn't tell me to clean up the
rest of it that's weaponized and
competence he's playing stupid to
basically
win argument no I mean don't come in
Nostradamus here but I suspect it was a
U2 uh or a couple
um and I would imagine Richard is one of
those that's probably quite guilty of
weaponized
he is tremendously competent in many
respects
household Jewels but I have to he's not
bad on that but I have to say when it
comes to looking for things the most
cursory glance around a room for a lost
item results in nowhere to be found
sorry can't find it anyway and Paula
you'll relate to this I do you find it
in about two seconds precisely where you
told them it was yes anything to say
have you experienced weaponizing
Commodities uh every day I have
experienced it clearly not in the last
14 years of a very very Blissful
marriage but I have experienced it but
remember we don't only see that type of
behavior at home we also see it in the
workplace and that unfortunately causes
significant issues in the workplace as
well as if I leave my like to take my
suit off after this the show tonight and
just leave it lying around for Kerry my
brilliant assistant if I leave it for
her to pick up is that weaponized
incompetence absolutely or or if you for
example
um just forget that uh you were supposed
to have researched X Y and Z and you
expect one of the Fantastic Runners who
work for you to compile a report for you
you could have done that yourself I mean
is there a grading here like if you're
the Hunter and provider of the house oh
which I am you bring in the big bucks
you work the long hours are you entitled
to down tools
that's a big if are you entitled to
basically be incompetent when it comes
to that I actually think that I'm going
to adopt I'm going to please
yeah because I can get in serious
trouble play the record show Richard's
eyes finally was shut up at the idea of
dipping his head over the parapet of
weaponized incompetence which says it
all yeah big door man good to see you
back I'm so the next Donald Trump facing
legal terminal what about the state of
President Biden some say he's brought
the new ship and economic stability to
Stormy Waters others say he's quite
literally asleep at the wheel will
debate the leader of the Free World next
foreign
[Music]
Morgan uncensored in New York City
tonight on Piers Morgan uncensored in
Kiev Ukraine tonight on Piers Morgan's
Special Edition from cancer tonight a
special edition appears more than
uncensored Martina navratulations do you
believe you can win this war so are you
gonna run again I think a lot of people
are going to be very happy yes I feel
betrayed they're trying to force you out
yes not only the coach but the other two
or three guys there around all these
people protesting just don't get it many
of them don't isn't that slightly
patronizing
I would call it you know
do you think we should have psychiatric
assessments I'd be there for weeks did
you keep quiet I'm trying to read a book
thanks bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bin
sexy where are they where's their
children
it's from that much cushier gel that
galane Max will agree to be interviewed
for the very first time I obviously wish
I'd never met him your ship taking your
head the British people are up in arms
Boris Johnson is out as British prime
minister the conservative party can
certainly win the next election can we
yes
this is the Royal team question is did
he say yes I have taken drugs and they
bent the rules to give them the Visa or
lied on the visa application form and
therefore got it
[Music]
what is a woman me
yeah let it roll a woman is given to the
man in marriage Andrew You're simply
wrong I've been a terrible liar that's
true I mean would you be prepared to say
that I've been a terrible liar are you
sorry you said that
no nothing it matters you should
absolutely not you should be interview
adjourned
[Music]
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving us Rhonda sanctimonious
or meatball Rock I've seen you clown
Tommy Fury so please go easy on me bro
you weren't asked to give evidence to
the grand jury I have nothing to hire
I'm the only one that has been telling
the troops you had to come up against a
team and had a Russian player would you
shake that no chance no chance it's life
and death This Is War Pass Morgan
what went wrong she said well I've only
got two years and I said you'll have two
months if you carry on like this what's
your response to him the whole nation
deserves to know what happened you don't
drink never taken drugs you're stinking
Rich should we be concerned
real opinions real debate is about you
and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that was a joke
foreign
[Music]
Americans seem to view these seemingly
unavoidable rematch between President
Biden and Donald Trump with a sense of
impending doom the president's age is a
major concern he's now using shorter
steps to board Air Force One after a
string of embarrassing stumbles
Democrats I hope that his political
success will spur him to re-election and
we'll debate that in a moment it's a
Relentless volley of verbal blunders
that look increasingly likely to define
the 80 year old president's Legacy
all right God Save the Queen man
Vladimir and I we I should shouldn't be
so familiar Mr zielinski and I uh well
Mr President Mr President yeah I've had
Vladimir Putin been weakened by recently
best it's hard to tell but he's clearly
losing the war in Iraq happy birthday to
you happy birthday dear Valley yeah
[Music]
it doesn't make edifying viewing really
joining me now is best-selling author of
new book The Biden malaise Kimberly
strassel and the Fox News host Jessica
Taylor well welcome to both of you all
right Kimberly uh you've written a book
about the Biden malaise many people feel
that uh Joe Biden is looking like a man
really feeling his age now and that that
is beginning to be an embarrassment for
him for the US on the world stage and
for the Democrats what do they do about
this
well I think what's remarkable is just
how rapid that change has been appears I
mean things were a little shaky even as
he campaigned but three years on no one
can avoid it anymore I'm very much
struck by the number of times now the
media feels that they can talk about it
it's such a central subject whereas not
so long ago it was taboo and I think
it's really up to Democrats to deal with
this the president seems intent on
running uh even though many in his party
at least quietly have a lot of concerns
about that and what's remarkable to me
is that you aren't having a repeat of
the Carter years where somebody other
than Robert Kennedy stands up and
challenges the presidency because I
think they'd have a far better shot of
winning that primary against Biden uh
than what happened against Carter back
in the 70s well Jessica Taylor do you
feel comfortable if you're completely
honest that Joe Biden was still what 18
months away from the next election and
if he was to win another four years so
that would be nearly six years is more
when you look at that at him now do you
see somebody physically and mentally
competent enough to do a six-year
stretch as president the most difficult
job in the world arguably
not not arguably I think pretty
indisputably
um yes I see someone who can do it but I
do see someone as Kimberly said who has
slowed down from even when he was
campaigning in uh 2015 sorry well he was
thinking about writing then um in 2020
and that's something that Democrats are
definitely taking note of there have
been a lot of whisper campaigns you see
it all over the pages of the New York
Times
um people that clearly are not ready to
attach their names to it but are
concerned about the future of this but I
do understand why he's running again he
has a huge record to be proud of and to
be able to talk to the American people
about and you're seeing that actually
reflected now there's a new Monmouth
poll out today where Biden is beating
Trump in the hypothetical matchup that
looks like it will become Reality by
seven points it feels like the tide is
shifting a little bit in terms of how
people feel about the economy I think a
lot of that is due to the success of
bidenomics as he calls it so yes would I
rather it was the 55 year old version of
Joe Biden sure but this is what we have
now and what he has been able to
accomplish I think is what's really
overriding concerns about that for the
Democrats I mean what's interesting I
think Kimberly is that the Republicans
have their own problem which is that
Trump has now been indicted uh twice we
have a third set of indictments coming
we believe imminently there may be
indeed a full set coming after that
completely unprecedented territory and
there's a belief I think in Washington
that Trump May well Barrel his way
through all this to be the Republican
nominee but hasn't got a chance of
winning a general election certainly not
with Independence you've been completely
put off by this barrage of criminal
indictments so the Republicans have
their own issues here
um if it was Donald Trump Joe Biden
might think you know what I may not be
the man I was as Jessica rightly said
um but I can still beat Donald Trump but
he may be right
well I think he may be right too I mean
this is one of the main arguments
against Donald Trump is that he has not
won in recent elections and we can see
that record of it uh I think the problem
that the Republicans have at the moment
is that this is turning into a repeat of
2016. when you go look at Donald Trump
and his poll numbers I don't know how
accurate those are they seem to match
pretty much about what he had in the
2016 primary at 35 percent maybe 40
percent support among certain Republican
primary voters that means that the
majority of the Republican party doesn't
want him to be the nominee and yet there
are so many competitors in the field
that they are dividing the vote so
there's going to have to be a fisher-cut
bait moment for the rest of these
candidates as they get closer to those
Iowa caucuses if they are not polling
beyond the low single digits they get
out and allow somebody who's got a
better chance to consolidate some
support right let me just Biden's public
approval rating is about 41 percent
close to the lowest level of his
presidency 54 disapprove of him as
president as performers his ratings
almost identical to where Trump's was at
the same point in his presidency Obama's
by contrast was 46 at this stage in his
first term so he's got a lot of work to
do here and the problem I see is that
every time he has one of these gas or
stumbles verbal or physical it gets put
on Recycle uh in the 24 hours news cycle
boom boom boom boom boom we just run a
whole set of highlights real just now
and flashes around and that becomes the
constant stick to beating with is he
able to communicate the message of the
record that he has in the context of all
this other stuff which is clearly from
the Optics really bad for him
yeah obviously it's hard to go into an
election if people what they're seeing
is you tripping over sandbags which that
was the advanced person's fault that
shouldn't have been there but it's not
good for anyone in terms of the approval
rating yes he's below Obama but Obama
did have points that were much lower
than that it didn't happen right when he
was heading into the 2012 re-election
cycle but all of these presidents do
have their moments and when Trump was at
approval ratings around there or below
he also had the fact that he was so
polarizing and that's the thing about
Joe Biden he just isn't as polarizing as
a Donald Trump or even as some other
Democrats people have no Joe Biden
they're familiar with him over the
Decades of service and he just does in
turn moderate voters off and
Independence off in the same way that a
further left Democrat might and to
Kimberly's point about what's going on
in the Republican side of all of this I
thought initially when DeSantis was
getting in that he was going to be the
person that everyone could coalesce
around as the alternative to Trump I
feel that he has not run a great
campaign so far that he has been
disappointing in a lot of ways shown
that he's not ready for the proverbial
prime time of this moment and there's a
lot of time to go but you can't look to
the Republican side now and say that's
the guy or that's the gal that they
should be banding together that'll stand
up the best against Joe Biden and that
makes it the Trump Biden rematch that we
all expected and Biden is still the guy
who doesn't turn people off as much as
the other guy yeah I do think that's a
really valid point that even a sort of
two-thirds strength Biden could still
defeat Trump because Trump is so
divisive and as all these criminal
indictments swirling around him which
cannot it cannot be good I mean it can
be good to win a republican nomination
but it can't be good to win a general
election I just don't think most
Americans who sit in the middle are
going to be anything other than put off
by that don't you think Kimberly
well yes I think that's a very valid
point I'm also really struck by the
degree that Democrats continue to bank
on Joe Biden's win on the basis of a
rematch with Donald Trump I would like
to consider what this race would
actually look like by contrast if you
suddenly had a very Dynamic uh 50 year
old Republican nominee that was not
Donald Trump who had a record for
instance like DeSantis does down in
Florida I mean if you dig in to Joe
Biden's poll numbers really dig in you
know you might think Americans tend to
look back at the 1970s and think oh that
terrible bad 70s the Jimmy Carter
presidency you know Joe Biden when it
comes to the handling of the economy
doesn't even pull as well as Jimmy
Carter and those are the issues that
people go to vote on so right now the
party is is again banking that they're
going to get someone that's even less
popular than Joe Biden they sure better
hope that turns out because they've got
a really big problem otherwise well you
know what I would do if I were the
Democrats and I'm not the Democrats I
can't even vote in your glorious
election but if I was I would be working
out a way to get someone like Gavin
Newsom to be the nominee uh come what
may and actually I think I I could
actually imagine a scenario here where
in the end you end up with Newsom via
DeSantis or Junkin actually
I mean I might be losing my marbles but
I do think that in the end may be what
happens and we don't end up with the
rematch everyone doesn't want to have
Jessica final word to you
yeah I mean I think that if Joe Biden
chooses of his own volition not to run
that you're absolutely going to see
Gavin Newsom I think Gretchen Whitmer as
well um her Super PAC is raising money
like wildfire she's fantastic the
party's really excited about her
obviously Kamala Harris will be part of
a primary um though I doubt frankly that
she would end up winning it
um and the contrast yes if you have 81
year he'll be 81 uh Joe Biden when we
start the debates and 45 year old
DeSantis for instance or Tim Scott or
Nikki Haley that is going to be very
Stark for people but it's not as easy as
many Republicans think for the
Republican Party writ large whoever is a
representative to get away from some of
their extreme positions Rhonda Santa
signed a six-week heartbeat bill in
Florida when the majority of Americans
are firmly against it
I think you know if you chase down that
road to get the nomination for the party
it's fine but to win a general election
on the back of that that can be very
difficult listen thank you both very
much indeed expert analysis much
appreciated thank you your debuts on
Piers Morgan Center I hope not the last
time I see you both thank you very much
know congratulations on the book bye-bye
yes Kimberly the book is called the
Biden malaise how America bounces back
from Joe Biden's dismal repeat of the
Jimmy Carter years I have to serve
interview Jimmy Carter a few times I
think he's one of the all-time great
Americans so the good news for Joe Biden
maybe if he does become the new Jimmy
Carter that in 50 years time everyone
remember him with great reverence uh
thank you both very much indeed Ron says
that next the four-star general David
Petraeus LED American forces in Iraq and
Afghanistan and ran the CIA who does me
live next to talk Ukraine
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
foreign
[Music]
Ukraine and Putin sustained heavy losses
not to mention barely surviving a coup
by the head of his own mercenary group
former president Trump claims he'd
sealed Peace by threatening Putin with
even more monetary support and he'd do
it all in 24 hours apparently and by
telling president zielinski he needs to
consider a deal despite the wildly
different rhetoric that's pretty much
the exact same strategy as President
Biden's all of which indicates that no
one really has much of a clue about how
to end this war or when it will end well
who better to answer that question
potentially the former CIA director and
former commander of U.S forces in
Afghanistan and Iraq General David
Petraeus whose new book conflict the
evolution of warfare from 1945 to
Ukraine is out in October General great
to have you back on the program thank
you very much indeed for joining me
good to be with you pierce thanks where
are we with this War I can't give anyone
better qualified to assess
well we're about a month into the summer
offensive for the ukrainians and they
have already had to make adaptations you
know the old saying that no plan
survives contact with the Enemy uh and
that has been the case here and I've
been impressed by the way the ukrainians
have really learned from early
challenges that they had making their
way through these very extensive
anti-tank and anti-personnel minefields
tank ditches trench lines dragons teeth
and other obstacles and so what they've
had to do is forgo for now the kind of
massive maneuver combined arms
operations that a lot of us had hoped
might be possible at some point but this
is not yet that point so what they're
having to do is set conditions they are
in fact in the words of the chief of
Defense staff of the UK which captures
this very well they are they are going
to starve stretch and strike the Russian
forces starving they are carefully
trading the Russian headquarters
logistical sites Reserve Force assembly
areas artillery units drone elements and
the front lines themselves and they're
working their way painstakingly through
these minefields with Soldiers with
sappers Engineers rather than with the
kind of massive breaching capabilities
that we would have been able to bring to
bear with air cover over top of it
carpet bombing the entire Minefield and
so forth they don't have that and so
they are adapting they're also
stretching they're ensuring that the
Russians have to stay stretched out
across the 600 mile Front Line This is
an enormous distance remember that just
in the fight to Baghdad from Kuwait to
Baghdad when I was a two-star for
example that's 150 miles less than this
600 miles and we thought that was a very
long way and required extraordinary
Logistics to keep it all moving so
they're doing that as well and then when
the conditions are right when they've
conducted probing effects that identify
for them the locations where they will
be able to unleash this new combined
arms capability with Western tanks in
infantry fighting Vehicles then I think
you'll see them achieve the kind of
breakthrough that many of us hope they
can achieve during the summer and
perhaps even a fall offensive they're
going to keep at this there's no
question that they recognize the
imperative of achieving results in this
offensive I was just there in early June
in key for a week that was the clear
sense that I got and the clear
determination that they conveyed so
that's where we are now we should note
that they have already taken uh in the
first five weeks or so of this summer
offensive more ground than the Russians
took really since the early months of
the offensive certainly much more than
they achieved during their winter
offensive but that's not a huge amount
it's about a hundred square miles or so
uh so far they could retake Bach moot
that's the one location where there
could be a breakthrough in the weeks
that lie ahead because the Russians
didn't have a chance to establish as
formidable defenses there as they have
throughout the South uh where they had
many many months to prepare these belts
of minefields trenches and so forth let
me ask you a couple of supplementaries
on that first of all the use of cluster
bombs cluster Munitions we ban them here
one of a hundred countries the UK which
does not support their use America is
not signed up to that and President
Biden has green lit there do you have
any moral qualms I know the Russians
have been using them but they are you
know very controversial Weaponry because
of the debris that they leave afterwards
the threat to civilians in the years
after their use and so on do you have
any moral problem with America sending
cluster Munitions to to the ukrainians
I agree with the decision that was made
in fact I was a proponent of it for the
following reasons peers first you noted
this area is already heavily infested
with uh Russian cluster bombs that have
been used that have a much higher dud
rate than do the American cluster
Munitions that are being provided that
can be shot out of artillery and also uh
out of rockets second they need the
additional artillery ammunition and this
will be very effective in going after
some of the targets that I described
they're seeking to a trip particularly
for example those in front line trenches
artillery units and so forth it's a very
impressive uh and effective area weapon
in that regard third the dud rate is
actually quite low it's not the one
percent that is the threshold for that
agreement that you mentioned the UK is a
signatory too but it's certainly well
under 2.5 percent and then most
importantly I think is this is not uh
we're not dumping these on another
country Free Soil Ukraine is not dumping
these all over some neighboring country
they're dumping it on they're using it
on their own territory knowing that they
will have to clear these areas later on
in order to liberate that territory and
I think at the end of the day it should
be up to them they're also not a
signatory uh one particular issue let me
ask you if you were running this
operation uh you would want air fire
you'd want air cover that's the quickest
way it seems to me to try and push the
Russians out at the moment you know
they're not getting much air cover at
all right so what what is the answer to
that is it going to be a point in this
war where if Ukraine is actually going
to Prevail and throw the Russians out of
the donbass for example they're going to
need
heavy air cover on it
there's no question about that and this
is one of the uh decisions that I felt
took too long to make the U.S has now
certainly acceded to the uh desire of
certain countries that have the F-16
it's the most ubiquitous fighter bomber
uh in the NATO Arsenal uh but of course
the U.S had to approve the transfer of
those aircraft uh and then we're also
supporting the training in various
Munitions and so forth but but again I
wish that we had done that earlier this
was an inevitable decision we could see
that the mig-29s and other uh old Soviet
Bloc if you will Eastern block uh
aircraft in the Ukrainian arsenal were
gradually being depleted uh there just
aren't any more in the NATO countries
that had them they've all transferred
them to Ukraine and so that was
inevitable now I should note look what
the U.S has done together with its key
allies and UK would be right at the top
of that list and other NATO and Western
countries has been extraordinary not
just keeping the alliance together
Gather in all different aspects but in
providing over 42 billion dollars worth
of arms ammunition and other material
it's a staggering quantity Millions
literally of rounds of one five five
millimeter Helens or ammunition but the
aircraft decision the tank decision a
few others took a bit longer than they
needed to and that has now been made but
it won't be available this new air power
won't be available in time for this
particular summer offensive I would not
think and again that is only one
component though of the kind of
comprehensive approach that is required
yes yes
I understand that I want to wait just
with you give me a one word answer if
you can it's not can Ukraine win the war
do you think they will win it
well you have to Define winning uh at
the end of the day peers and I think
that at the end I don't think they
Define it to you
resolution yeah I mean it's zelenski
told me that he wouldn't give up an inch
of land so put part the Crimea to one
side is you know something that happened
before and has to be perhaps negotiated
at a different a different time but the
donbass region for example the territory
the Russians have taken
I don't think they're going to give an
inch of that up voluntarily so does
Victory look like they have that land
back and is that achievable
I think it is achievable uh it remains
to be seen whether the capabilities were
provided are enough to enable that
achievement there's no question about
the sheer resolve of the entire
population of Ukraine including those
certainly on the front lines but
everyone else as well this is their war
of independence peers and they're
approaching it this way they're
absolutely determined they're also
incredibly Innovative
adaptable resourceful and so the
qualities are all there and I think the
question we have to continually ask is
when do the Russian forces start to
crumble yes uh got turmoil in their
upper ranks they've had their Deputy
Commander killed by a Storm Shadow
reportedly provided by the UK fired
pagosian although now he may be back in
favor there's fired a two-star combined
arms Army Commander the troops are
complaining they're treated poorly when
does this manifest itself I agree it
real surrenders that's I think the
question that we have to answer and of
course it will come about by the
ukrainians putting enormous pressure on
them but having changed now from the
initial uh plans that they may have had
very likely to achieve their objectives
of this offensive General Petraeus
brilliant to talk to you I'm going to
leave it there but thank you very much
indeed to joined the program always
thank you thank you all the best and
since the next a course of Liberties
have denounced veganism in the market of
vegan foods is imploded have I won the
plant-based argument notorious activist
vegan booty doesn't think so as you
joins me next
[Music]
good evening I'm Piers Morgan uncensored
in New York City tonight on Piers Morgan
uncensored in Kiev Ukraine tonight on
Piers Morgan on Special Edition from
cancer tonight a special edition appears
more than uncensored Martinez making me
cry again you believe you can win this
this week so are you gonna run again I
think a lot of people are going to be
very happy yes I feel betrayed they're
trying to force you out yes not only the
coach but the other two or three guys
there around these people protesting
just don't get it many of them don't
isn't that slightly patronizing
I would call
it psychiatric assessment I'd be there
for weeks did you keep quiet I'm trying
to read a book
thanks bear and Chuck it where it
belongs in the bay
we're all about this where are they
where's their children
why isn't someone on the roof where's
the castle it's from that much cushier
gel that Elaine Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
obviously wish I'd never met him you're
shaking your head the British people are
up in arms Boris Johnson is out as
British prime minister the conservative
party can certainly win
yes
this is the Royal team question is did
he say yes I have taken drugs and they
bent the rules to give them the Visa or
lied on the visa application form and
therefore got it
[Music]
what is a woman me
yeah let it roll a woman is given to the
man in marriage Andrew You're simply
wrong I've been a terrible liar that's
true I mean would you be prepared to say
that I've been a terrible liar are you
sorry you said that
no nothing it matters you should be
absolutely not you should be interview
adjourned
which is your favorite nickname that
Trump's giving us Rhonda sanctimonious
or meatball Rock I see new clown Tommy
Fury so please go easy on me bro please
go easy you weren't asked to give
evidence to the grand jury I have
nothing to hire I'm the only one that
has been telling the truth if you had to
come up against a team and had a Russian
player would you shake that no chance no
chance it's life and death This Is War
Pass Morgan
what went wrong she said well I've only
got two years and I said you'll have two
months if you carry on like this what's
your response to him the whole nation
deserves to know what happened you don't
drink never taken drugs you're stinking
Rich should we be concerned
real opinions real debate is about you
and your opinions if you're thinking
about it we're talking about it
it's all about me that was a joke
foreign
coming up on the talk Coots says sorry
to Nigel farage in the account closure
route but it's been revealed that the
bank has done business with dictators
Russian oligarchs and the Mafia the EU
u-turns after appearing to endorse an
Argentine name for the Falkland Islands
and Prince Harry's book becomes the most
thinned holiday read for Brits that's
all at nine o'clock
[Music]
thank you
welcome back to Peaceful glasses the
celebrities are denouncing veganism on
mass the market for plant-based rules
fall off a cliff it was increasingly
likely that the rest of the world agrees
with me which is often what happens with
issues Infamous activist Tash Pearson
better known as vegan booty he's on a
mission to change people's minds by all
means necessary so his veganism here to
stay or As Dead As a stake on my plate
later this evening I'm joined by vegan
booty Tash Peterson and I'll kick host
and fox commentator Tommy Lauren all
right
would you go by the name vegan or began
it's Miss Booty or what Tash Peterson is
fine yes veganism is going out of
fashion meatless Farm announcer only
production beyond meat shares crashed 95
uh most vegan companies in this country
lack of consumer demands now I think
people have got fed up with it I think
one of the reasons is they're Fed Up
would be shouting at you you're one of
these people that runs into restaurants
and plays you know sounds from screaming
animals and other trials and so on I
know you get passionately about it I
think it's very off-putting it's a bit
like the just stop oil protesters doing
a lot of their stuff it just annoys
people has the opposite effect to what
you hope no I don't think so at all I
think it brings more attention to the
animal Holocaust animals are subjected
to rape torture enslavement abuse and
murder and I'm bringing light to that
and I'm seeing why would you use the
words why use the word holocaust
Holocaust is the mass extermination of
more than six million Jewish people by
Adolf Hitler and the Nazis one Holocaust
in history why would you why would you
have people know that as the Holocaust
why would you use that kind of very
emotive language knowing it would offend
a lot of people well it's just a factual
statement if you look at the definition
of a holocaust it is Slaughter or
destruction on a mass scale multiple
Holocaust have occurred throughout human
history and non-human animals can be
subjected to the same atrocities that
humans can in fact it's the largest
Holocaust in history with three trillion
individuals brutally murdered every year
for human food consumption all right
Tommy you're from a ranching family I
don't know about you I just find I don't
mind people being vegans you don't want
to eat me it's absolutely fine I get
some of the reasons why they don't want
to personal choice you know they care
about animals and so on although I would
point out animals eat a lot of animals
just for the record naturally
um what do you feel about this whole
vegan debate are we getting bored with
it it seems to me up from all the sales
in the UK and stuff it's kind of going
out of fashion like it was a fad for a
lot of people that have gone back to
munching meat
well veganism is an effort so I must be
Tommy sorry
yeah I think a lot of people realize
that it wasn't in fact the healthier
choice because when they choose this
beyond meat or these other substitutes
it's actually just packed with different
fillers so it's not actually this
cleaner option like a lot of people
thought at the onset of the whole vegan
craze but I gotta tell you speaking of
the animal Holocaust which I think is a
ridiculous thing to say I'm from a
ranching family I'm from a ranching
State there's nobody that cares more for
their animals than those in the ranching
and farming communities now I'm against
Factory ranching and farming as well by
the way I think that that's atrocious
I'm an animal lover but as somebody who
comes from a ranching family I can tell
you that ranchers and Farmers care for
their livestock dearly yes it does at
the end of the day turn into a product
for human consumption but that doesn't
mean that it is always inhumane that
it's always discussing that it's this
animal Holocaust or genocide as your
guest was referring to it as it's also
really annoying to me when people try to
say that animals are causing climate
change I mean if you don't want to eat
animals because you love animals or you
have a health reason that prevents you
from eating animals that's fine but this
whole environmental craze that we need
to get rid of animals because they're
causing climate change that's also a
step too far and part of the reason why
this whole vegan craze is going out the
window yeah and being a Bear Grylls said
recently I was a vegan quite a few years
uh he said but I thought it was good for
the environment I thought it was good
for my health and through time and
experience and knowledge and study I
realized I was wrong on both counts it
was bad for the environment bad for his
health he was never a vegan in the first
place and there's an ethical view again
murder if you're against animal abuse
and murder you never contribute it to it
again he wrote a vegan cookbook it
wasn't actually a vegan cookbook it
contained animal abuse and you're saying
bad girls was a fake vegan he never was
a vegan he was a vegan no he said he's
alive he's not a lie huh no well I've
looked at the cookbook you may not have
no more products you may not have liked
the fact that he went back to eating
meat but he was a vegan for quite a
while
that label all the time but if they
actually truly hold their ethical view
against animal abuse and murder then
they would never turn back on veganism
you know Tommy over here I railed
against uh vegan sausage rolls I didn't
like the way they appropriated the
language of meat products I don't think
vegan companies should be allowed to use
words like sausage rolls or steaks
because that's meat
yeah exactly and they're filled with soy
and fillers and other disgusting things
that you actually don't want to put into
your body and meat tastes good that's
why all of these fake meat companies try
to make it taste like meat it never
actually comes to fruition because it
still tastes like crap and I would also
point out during covid when we were
having shortages in the grocery store if
you looked for meat it was sometimes
hard to find at least here in the U.S
but that beyond meat crap that was
always available because people don't
want it the consumers are deciding that
they want maybe an organic option maybe
a free range option but people still
want to eat meat and you can eat meat
and respect animals at the same time it
can be done it's been done since the
dawn of time but we are beyond beyond
meat now we're going back to munching
meat I love meat I won't be this word
otherwise and I think there are better
tactics to running into restaurants and
playing noises of screaming animals
personally thank you for coming on the
program uh Tasha and thank you to Tommy
as always whatever you're up to Keep It
Uncensored good night
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign